in a few days in IKEA staging a race in
Monza Italy where competitors will be
attempting one of the greatest feats of
athleticism in history a sub 2 hour
marathon to do it Nikes tap three of the
world's very best long-distance runners
and if any of them is to break two hours
he'll need to maintain an average pace
and at least 13.1 miles per hour for 120
consecutive minutes now 13.1 miles per
hour is obviously very fast but it's not
so fast as to be unreachable by even an
average runner the challenge is in
maintaining that pace and so in that
respect what distinguishes a world-class
distance runner from an average one to
answer that question we've done two
things first we invited members of wires
running club to see how long they could
last on a treadmill running at 13.1
miles per hour second we called this guy
my name is Michael Joyner I'm a
physician researcher at the Mayo Clinic
and I'm an expert in human performance
so how do we doing the treadmill test
[Applause]
actually it might not be for everyone
joiners not affiliated with the Nike
initiative but he has been studying the
marathon's to our threshold for decades
in 1991 he published a paper exploring
the theoretical limits of marathon
running he calculated that an ideal
athlete running under ideal conditions
could run a marathon in one hour 57
minutes of 58 seconds we asked him to
explain why none of us will ever run a
marathon that fast but why one of these
guys just might the three things that
determine distance running performance
are vo2 max for maximal oxygen uptake
lactate threshold and running economy or
efficiency vo2 max is basically a
measure of how much oxygen you can get
out of the air into your tissues it's
typically expressed in units of
milliliters of oxygen per kilogram of
body weight per minute if you don't
exercise but are otherwise young and
healthy your vo2 max is likely in the
30s or 40s if you do exercise by running
swimming or biking you probably see
values in the 40s and 50s and if you're
really serious with your training you
can even creep into the low to mid 60's
that's still nowhere near the numbers
you see in professional marathoners the
elite athletes will be attempting the
sub-2 marathon have vo2 max values in
the 70s or even 80s so they have double
the vo2 max values of mere mortals and
it's a little bit because they're small
men like putting a v8 in into a
motorcycle if you think of vo2 max as
the size of your engine relative to the
size of your car then lactate threshold
is a little like the redline meter on
your cars - it's the level of effort at
which lactate and other metabolites
start accumulating exponentially in your
blood that's a limit you want to avoid
overshooting in an endurance race it's
usually given as a percentage of your
vo2 Max and for untrained people it's
around 60% with training the number of
mitochondria in your skeletal muscle and
the number of capillaries around each
skeletal muscle go way up this permits
people to start to work at 70 80 even 85
or 90 percent of their max so it's like
going from having
to cobbler with a red line on it in your
car at 5,000 to a Ferrari with one at 8
or 9,000 that leaves running economy
basically how efficient are you there's
a lot of theories about why some runners
are more efficient than others and most
of them boil down to biomechanics so
basically the length and size of your
legs how much you bob up and down when
you're running where your foot lands
relative to your center of gravity even
the flexibility of your tendons but we
actually know a lot less about running
the economy than we do about either
lactate threshold or vo2 max the fact
that leads to a lot of myths and
misconceptions about what makes running
more or less efficient a big one is that
running on your forefoot or your mid
foot is more efficient than landing on
your heel but that's not exactly true
in 2012 biomechanics researcher named
Ian hunter shot this footage of elite
distance runners competing in a 10,000
meter race now I want you to focus on
their feet if you watch closely you'll
notice that their strides actually vary
quite a bit some runners land on the
forefoot some light on their mid foot
and still others land field first all of
which suggests there's actually no
single most efficient way to run in fact
it tends to vary quite a bit on a
case-by-case basis
the irony here is that even if we don't
totally understand it running economy is
the one variable that's most sensitive
to technological enhancement which is
why so many shoe companies are
experimenting with ultralight materials
super springy foams and propulsive
carbon fiber plates all of which by the
way Nike has included in its new shoe
which it claims will boost the
efficiency of its runners by as much as
four percent which is crazy especially
when you consider how efficient these
guys are to begin with the one thing
that's been noted about the East
Africans is not so much that they have
very high vo2 Max values or anything
unusual out of this world or lactate
thresholds although they're plenty high
what's really interesting about these
individuals is a large number of East
Africans have terrific running economy
or efficiency us on the other hand not
so much
[Applause]